Đói đá, lợp bảo dìm xa ủy nhanh nhìn không chăm tư quý định vực quý quyền chân người khác, thực hiện bảo dìm xa hội.
Có hiệu lực tuổi đà mời hai tháng.
Theo phản anh của các quan bảo dìm xa hội và một số địa phương,
lợi giung này phas sinh một số bắt cập trung việc làm dấy quý quyền tiết.
Khi hết hiệu lực trong người hai tháng.
Bên đối với người xa khoải yêu như chừng hợp không thể làm tiếp dấy quý quyền.
Và cũng là phas sinh chifey đối với chừng hợp phải làm dấy quý quyền tại phán phòng công chính.
Đấy cạnh đó, quy định này cũng chung hợp toàn như quy định pham rật bên xa sự.
Không sẽ ăn thời gian yếu quyền và đi nghĩa sự đổi bộ xung thiêu hưởng bảo thời gian có hiệu lực tuổi đà của việc quyền.
Tuy nhiên một số địa phương trong rằng nên sự như quy định hiện hành để thật lợi chung công các quan lý đối tượng thủ hưởng.
Từ đó, phải sự thảo lật vô đồ vụ để xuất hai phương án,
cô thể phương án thương nhất là bảo hiệu lực tuổi đà của việc tuổi quyền như hiện hành là mời hai tháng.
Hợp việc thực hiện quyền thác quy định của phép rật bên xa sự.
Bởi phương án này thì việc quả lý đối tượng thủ hưởng phải được cơ quan bảo hiểm xa hội thực hiện thông qua bị kết nối,
chia sẻ thông tin giữ liệu với các cơ sử liệu của xa, cơ sử liệu chuyên ngành.
Và chính nhận với học sau mình thông tin đủ điều kệnh thủ hưởng chỉ đốt bảo hiểm xa hội của người thủ hưởng.
Phương án thương án là giữa việc quy định hiện hành.